this is a production of Cornell
University
so speaking at 10 a.m. it is 10 a.m. I
guess we'll get started for everybody I
am Carlos de Monte I'm the program
manager here at our Coronel turfgrass
program also just an extension look as
well I'll be here
moderating most weeks as you can see on
the webinars are scheduled for this
Thursday sports session we're going to
do this every other Thursday so the next
one I think is April 9th at 10:00 a.m.
just a couple logistics here so there's
a chat function on the right I'll be
posting any links that while Frank's
presenting today that might be relevant
I'll be posting those online links there
so you can find that there's also a Q&A
function so if you ever have questions
that's the place to ask your question
allows us to see them and mark them as
they're answered or not we'll record the
webinars as I said and then just a brief
comment on the format so we're gonna try
and keep this quick every week you know
15 to 20 minutes we'll have a topic we
want to focus on this week obviously the
situation with the Koba 19:00 virus and
thinking about the essentiality of turf
is what Frank's gonna talk about we'll
try and keep that to 15 to 20 minutes
and then of course we want to answer the
questions you guys have so again that
Q&A function is where to find that so
without further ado Frank I'm gonna hand
it off to you and we'll get started
great thanks Carl you can hear me okay
yep well good to see everybody and I'm
so sorry to be standing in front of you
in a Yankee hat it would have been key
backdrop and not be talking to you about
opening day and spring a face of all and
for those of us that are sports
enthusiasts and especially like me a
rabid Yankee fan
it's another you know it's adds insult
to injury all the things that we're
sacrificing but remember these kinds of
things that were sacrificing are you
know the kinds of things that make life
so enjoyable but what matters most is
that we're all here and ultimately my
goal today is to talk to you about
supporting each other during these
difficult times and
and you know obviously this is not what
we're used to
you got the slides there Carl you can
see it
okay so we're just titling it supporting
each other through these difficult times
it seems my shirt has mowing patterns on
it too isn't that kind of cool at least
funny things that happen so I'm hoping
that we can shed some light on some
things where there might be a lot of
confusion we did this with the golf guys
yesterday the golf folks yesterday and
it went 45 minutes so you know we're
here to certainly for 45 minutes easily
an hour if you really need it but we're
trying to approach this in a much
different way than we have other kinds
of things like this in the past
obviously I'd be around in the spring
seeing many of you in person so we're
trying to replicate that and try to make
this as interactive as possible so I
want to get through some of the content
I want to share with you my thoughts on
the matter and then happy to take
questions for as long as you guys got
them so you know this is what we're
starting with right everybody's got to
keep each other safe the numbers and
things that we're seeing are certainly
alarming for especially for us here in
New York so I just want to stress to
everybody the importance from your
land-grant institution to keep
yourselves safe just to remind you
Cornell University is shuttered about
ten million dollars of agricultural
search this spring we are really
shuttering this place down and and of
course we have the luxury in many ways
to do that it is a big sacrifice just
want to reiterate the sacrifices
everyone's making economic and
personally for the health of others so
with that Cornell Cooperative Extension
maintains an extension disaster Network
webpage that addresses these issues from
a broader perspective but certainly
updates and safety issues that address
food agriculture and horticulture and of
course we're going to fall into the
horticultural component of this if you
are deemed essential now I have to say
it's not clear to me I couldn't find
anything that was saying whether
municipalities and school districts
certainly school districts are closed
and I know a lot of us here are on
minimum maintenance plans so so it's
hard to know some of the answers to this
thing so what one of the things that we
heard in our conference call this
morning with our regional
representatives that helped us put
short-cut together is you know can I
work if
I do what do i do you know what should I
do to keep everybody safe and then
what's allowed right and so
fundamentally safety first right this is
our mantra but if that's what we're
saying there are best management
practices for this right if you are
going to work if it's been deemed that
the things you need to do for your
sports fields specifically your sports
fields we're gonna have another webinar
tomorrow for lawn and landscaping
grounds but specifically for people who
have round ball sports or spring sports
particularly baseball that would be
happening now and the maintenance of
those things if you're still doing that
we want you to be aware of best
management practices under these
conditions now a lot of organizations
are putting these out there's probably
very specific ones that even your
facility might have and already adopted
that they're asking you to weigh in on
it I like the work Tom Ford did here at
Penn State University
to just give you an outline of the kinds
of variables that are involved Tom
really writes and very plain English
about the challenges we have about
lunchrooms about the way we generally
send out crews to work you know we're
talking about staggering crews if
somebody gets infected what happens then
so obviously there are some very
critical issues that we have to face if
we are going to work if we are going to
work so so that's the first place to
start for me as a extension turf
specialist I'm not a pandemic expert I'm
not a health expert I have to rely on
people who are translating health
information and getting it to you
I don't really can't answer specific
questions about these sorts of things I
think I would refer you to the places
where you can get more specific
information about districts and
municipalities and and what your
baseball or football club might be doing
but this is what I can tell you is a
good resource from our perspective where
it understands how we work right there's
a way we work in the sports turf
industry that is worth you reviewing
this before you move forward all right
now here's my goal for you to busy today
if
you're gonna work everybody's gonna say
well what's the minimum amount you got
to do it we don't want you out here will
you go and go home right everybody needs
to be home and that question is very
much dependent on well are they gonna
play on these fields a lot of these
sports are not allowed to be done
there's all kinds of regulations about
the kinds of sports that are allowable
and generally team sports where there's
crowding or going to be any physical
contact like in soccer or in baseball
when you're sliding and doing things I
mean obviously a catch might be okay but
who's touching the ball so if you are
getting traffic active traffic on your
fields you you might have to well
minimum maintenance means I got to get
this thing ready for play and here's
what I do for that but if you don't have
traffic now you step back and you say
well who's out there well people are out
there act passively passively
trafficking the place but there's no
focused traffic and I'm you know I'm not
gonna prepare to skin you know cuz we're
telling them not to play and if they
come out they're at risk Oh what about
risk listen there's a lot of questions
here we don't have answers to there's a
lot of questions I can't answer how much
risk are you at if you don't prepare the
field and people go use it under a
banned activity ah you got to put signs
up these are questions I actually cannot
answer yet not a lot of people can't
that's one of the problems so it's hard
to have confidence 100% confidence in
all your decisions but from you know how
do I do this work if you get traffic or
don't get traffic that's what's gonna
govern a lot of this look sorry so let
me give you three simple rules let me
give you three simple rules first do no
harm whatever you're going to do a
minimum maintenance plan should not be
trying to do things too early you know
we're hearing that people want to put
insecticides out right because I may not
be able to get my grub control down well
you start doing that now you could be
impacting beneficials in a very serious
way and if you're not mowing as much and
things are in flower and you're putting
insecticide in fact if you put anything
out and your turf isn't flower because
you're not mowing it
you run the risk of damaging beneficial
insects and we know how everybody feels
about pollinators these days so first do
no harm don't rush to do anything second
avoid that reflex reaction just because
you know he's done it that's like the
one that's going to take us down the
toilet here right
just because you've always done it
doesn't mean you're doing it now
especially if you don't have traffic
right
so and then you've got to start thinking
about strategic reductions can I start
and keep care minimal and my answer is
yes right there's a very simple very
strategic way to approach this so let's
go through some of the basics first off
the the forecasts are sort of suggesting
we're going to warm up there's going to
be a stall but certainly we're well
ahead of normal we may get a little bit
of a stall in the growing season but
we're way ahead of normal we're
expecting very warm conditions coming
forward and that is generally as the
growing season is going to progress now
in sports turf and in turf in general
we're so intimately associated with soil
temperature right that we should make
sure you're paying attention to this if
you have a way of monitoring your soil
temperature this is from our turf grass
forecast website Carl's going to put all
the links to all the things we're
talking about are gonna go on the chat
here and we'll be pushing them out
you'll be able to people who are
watching this recorded all those all
those links will be available to you
this is a good place to start
keep in mind roots are going to be
growing soils are releasing nutrients
just know top growth yet right so keep
an eye on soil temperatures I'm not
really worried about this until we're
getting into the into the low to mid 50s
and even down in in Maryland and BC
you're barely into the upper 40s yet now
this could change rapidly but with
moisture coming it may stay still very
cool now the long term outlook and again
if you're thinking about firing up an
irrigation system really the only people
that should be remotely considering it
are sand bass people but if you look at
the rainfall forecast here the
prediction that came out just on March
19th is saying we're expecting above
normal precipitation we've got a better
chance of above normal precipitation in
the Northeast so again not sure we need
to get out there and rush any water goal
this is probably the single most
important thing that everybody's talking
about it I had a number of wonderful
conversations yesterday you know when
you get into golf and they've started
applying PG ARS it's
are thinking about that on a regular
basis as a routine practice they think
about growth very different now if
you're using plant growth regulators I'd
encourage you to listen to the recording
we did yesterday about golf turf because
that's a very elaborate discussion now
for the purposes of this I would tell
you unless you've got high-performance
athletic fields you ought to be raised
and you know they're not getting used
all the time if you're normally mowing
your bluegrass at about an inch inch and
a half right I don't see any reason why
you can't go to two inches right so I
I'm really thinking in northern climates
two inches is a bare minimum height I
think most of you ought to be able to
get that a three to four inch rains
especially if you're not actively using
the fields right I'm not suggesting a
baseball infield should be let go to
four inches but certainly two and a half
three inches is perfectly reasonable now
why do that
well you do that because we know if you
follow the one-third rule if you don't
remove more than 30% of the foliage at
any one time you actually suppress the
growth rate but mowing grass just to
remove about 30% minimizes the amount of
mowing and minimizes growth over the
long term so the only effective way to
really reduce mowing and keep growth
slow is by following the one-third rule
and by raising to hide a cut you do a
significant amount to letting the grass
that having to go out there much mow
less obviously if you can get the height
all the way to four inches which is what
I'm going to tell my lawn and landscape
people tomorrow you can let it go to six
now people can say well that doesn't
look like it normally does and and then
you say well I don't know have you
noticed as a pandemic that maybe we
can't get out here so much so we're
trying to be mindful of this and I think
these are the kinds of conversations we
have to have with people moving forward
they're not easy but we're trying to
give you some science for listen I'm
trying to be out as little as possible
here's the easiest way to do it let me
raise the height of cut all right now
this is a solitary activity that can be
useful early in the season on sport
field I don't believe it's minimum
maintenance but it's something if you
want to get some work done make sure
you're sanitizing all your surfaces if
you're going out to do it because it can
help with a lot of factors I wouldn't
recommend it as a routine practice
during this time because it's really
only something you need when you're
actively playing on the field
so generally mowing I would tell you
don't rush check rope raise your height
mow 30% roll is a question mark and if
you're able as time passes consider
plant growth regulators and we'll get
into that more as the grass gets gets
growing and we're not able to get out
there and you're allowed to use plant
growth regulators go ahead and do it now
one last question before I leave mowing
and growth and soil temperatures and
things like that you notice I'm not
talking about nutrients I'm not talking
about fertilization because I don't
think you should be fertilizer I can't
think of a reason I couldn't come up
with a reason yesterday with really
smart people who were telling me yeah
northern climates now you got time you
got time especially if there's no
traffic a lot of times the only reason
you need traffic is to recover from some
damage that's there or to keep up with
traffic neither one of those things are
going to matter dramatically right now
especially if the fields aren't being
you so they know the story on
fertilizers if people are telling you to
rush out there and get your products
down number one before April 1st it's
against the law I don't want to remind
everybody against a law second if why do
you want to be stimulating growth when
you might not be able to deal with it
later on all right how about pests three
big ones crabgrass red thread
and the grubs Oh crabgrass red thread in
the grubs so these are the kinds of
things you should be thinking about but
again we're too early we're too early
there's nothing here for you to do yet
right
spend some time learn how to ID the
weeds the winter annuals should be
flowering now henbit chick weeds
annual bluegrass be flowering soon a lot
of good time to do some weed ID Jenny
down Tiffin and our weed Extension
Service has done a great job and putting
together this weed ID get out there and
start identifying plants take your kids
out teach them how to identify plants
Kyle wicking czar in soil insect
ecologist put together a spectacular
grub ID love Alec give you the size of
the grub and if you're thinking about
what you're going to see now you see the
bottom right hand corner where you can't
see the penny that's probably the size
of the monsters you're gonna be seeing
out there now now it's a good time to go
out there and look if you're in if
you're walking around your yard go out
where you think you might see some dry
grass peel it back take a look right you
learn how to do some ID stuff and you
know nothing better in a pandemic than
staring down the anal slit of a white
grub species
now crabgrass is a different story I
know we'll have a lot of reflex action
not so much in sports turf but certainly
in a lot of our grounds operations a lot
of reflex to get out there and put down
that pre-emergent crabgrass control and
I'll certainly be talking to the lawn
and landscape people about this tomorrow
but just for your information our
Cornell guidelines our weed control
section has this very table in it
looking at the length of control you get
from these products we have plenty of
time to get crabgrass products down
especially if one of the things you're
going to be doing is oversee right if
you're going to be overseen now of
course all this is out the window if
you're in the school districts where you
know you can't apply materials so it's
important to keep this in mind you've
got some time there's no rush here I
know everybody's telling you to get it
out but we've got until the soils really
into the mid-50s till the crabgrass gets
going now wrapping it up to on the
sports turf side something unique to
sports turf I think is the care of the
infield skins in our baseball fields
that were normally beginning active use
at this time well if it wasn't raining
of course and so if you're not getting
play really if any and you and your you
know is this essential know if you went
out once every couple of weeks and just
scratched it up wouldn't be the worst
thing but it you know you can get to it
when you get back now you're gonna say
well those points are gonna get big and
the roots are gonna screw up the clay
and yeah those things are going to
happen so you better tell people if I
can't come in and keep the vegetation
under control it's gonna take me a
little bit longer to get this field back
ready right we have to be prepared to
tell the people that we service that
there's going to be this lag time when
we get out now just like the economy is
going to have this bit of a lag before
we get going again everybody's going to
need this sort of prep time to get
themselves ready and if we have to
sacrifice a little bit of this now and
later for the things we're doing now by
not doing them you know those are
decisions that everybody's got to make
on a case-by-case basis so
here's what I can tell you if you let
the vegetation grow it's gonna take
longer to get it back into shape but I
think that's not a problem if you just
communicate the people listens it's
gonna take us a little bit longer hey
everybody's clean everybody's good
everybody got the antibody come on let's
fix the field together so I think
there's things to consider about what's
minimum maintenance here and so with
that call I'll pass it back to you and
you can stare at me at Yankee Stadium
and we can start taking questions yeah
so first question comes from Chris sicko
of course and he's got a good question
about fields that were trafficked in the
fall aggressively there was a fall you
sport and haven't really recovered so
there's thin areas and he's thinking
about weed recruit man crabgrass is in
the seed bank there is that a situation
in which you would say well you know
we're trying not to promote growth but
in that case is fertilizer of course
after April first something you would
consider even in a minimal maintenance
plan yeah that's a great question so as
I understand it just reflecting it back
it's if I've got a feel that got beat up
late into the season and has it
recovered fully I've got bare ground in
the gold mouths
I've got bare ground everywhere would
would helping that field recover be
considered part of minimum maintenance
and I I think the answer would be yes to
the extent that you're allowed to work a
fertilizer application or even seed
right I think the interim thing would be
maybe to see if maybe I would mow expose
the soil and and put down maybe a
hundred you know instead of the normal C
Dre died increase it by 50% and really
try to get a flash of density without
getting the growth I guess now that I'm
thinking through it I would say why not
seed first because you know it's not
getting traffic and you know mow get the
ground exposed because mowing will also
stimulate growth
mowing will begin to stimulate that
lateral growth as well and and I think
that's a way to do it and not provoke
long term growth because you know once
the ground starts to warm
naturally we're going to get that
release and we're gonna be like holy s
oh yeah
holy sugar we got--we I don't want this
and I promise you if you're gonna put
out any nitrogen bill said this
yesterday no Chrysler said this
yesterday you soluble sources don't use
a big slug of granule right that's going
to put seven tenths of a pound down
right you know and you're gonna get a
big urea bump right away that's what
these products are designed to do but
but that's the reflex action we have to
avoid now because if we can't get back
ammo and I can't fail hey and I get back
there and it's 8 inches everybody's like
well why is it inches well I put the
Pearl I don't why'd you do that Rossi
said oh well so let's think through this
right some of you may not have the
capacity to put out a liquid application
that might allow for lower rates there
are some high-grade anderson products
that you can put at lower rates but you
know you gotta have access through me
I'm available and do it right right
I like mowing and seeding I'd be I mean
I could be wrong about that but I would
say that's where I would start what do
you think Carl ok I like that idea and
then a similar question been polymer
he's asking about PGR usage and
typically he use those in the summer
where he's reducing mowing he's probably
mowing almost every day of the week
so you know thinking about PGR usage in
the spring maybe you can reflect on what
Bill and Doug we're talking about so
glad to have you been glad you joined us
good luck to all our our friends and
sports turf in Massachusetts you know
this is this is all of us in this
together so so here's what I can tell
you basically if you looked at Bill
crisis you know 10 years of study in
things five years of the last in pansy
right PGR use is very much got to be
governed by the growth rate of the grass
the slower the grass is growing right
the less PGR you need both in rate and
frequency right that there's two ways to
think about PGR you some glad we're
recording this because this could be
useful for other people later on there's
two things that are important that bill
is identified right is rate of product
and frequency from the pgrn for
the plant ends it's almost entirely
about how how much clippings you're
taking off on a regular basis what's the
growth rate the more it grows the more
PGR you need the more frequently you
need it right the easiest way to get
grass to grow faster is to cut it lower
and lower you know a lot of PT our work
has been focused span on putting green
stuff there's a little bit on sports
stuff but but for sure the putting green
stuff where they're cutting at 1/10 of
an inch seven days you know what I mean
those guys are pounding the PG arse now
you talked to Bill you come into the
fairway we just go up to 380 or half
inch you need significantly lower rates
significantly longer intervals right and
so you have to think about PGR use a
little bit differently when you're
cutting at a higher height a cut he
further says there's some goofy things
like low cut bluegrass bill said out
loud yesterday he's not sure they
produced gibberellins to any great
degree if you have you know low cut
bluegrass on some of your finer fields
he hasn't found a PGR that actually
regulates the growth of that grass so I
that's an outlier to me in some ways so
here's what I'd tell you Ben my
experience with these things are both
what's been studied and in and in you
know what we've seen in practice and ami
Foudy at Michigan State University has
been a regular user of proxy on her
Kentucky bluegrass field right I think
there are some products you can use on
higher cut turf bluegrass rye grass tall
fescue all of these products have label
recommendations that to be honest we
don't think a lot about it this time of
year I apply it the sports fields
because we want so much growth so here's
the rule here's where I'd start man
that's a long way of me saying his right
start trim it is by far the most
aggressive plant growth regulator Pacwa
Butte Rizzo the most affect effective
plant growth regulator you're going to
find there's a lot of these combo
products that are on the market what I
would do if I were you is I get onto the
green keeper app and I look at the
models they got
350 models of the frequency and timing
of doing things to regulate grass mowed
at different heights I'm not fluent
enough in it to give you specific
recommendations but here's what I can
say I wouldn't use a plant growth
regulator in a sports field until I
mowed it I'd want to make sure I had
some active growth and then once I got
green up I would consider going in there
and one of the things we will talk about
them moving forward is I can tolerate a
little phyto toxicity
I can get 80% reduction in growth before
I get Fido right in some cases so so you
you're you want to be sure to get get a
mowing down and then start preparing in
a week if you can for the beginning of a
growth regulator application depending
on how growth goes but applying it now
might not be as effective and and might
not it I just don't think we need to do
it yet that's at least what everybody's
saying yet but it's a great question if
you're allowed to do it yeah I agree
Frank and I think a lot of people are
trying to weigh the opportunity cost
faced I don't think about it as an
opportunity cost if I spray a PGR am I
gonna save enough mowings that I can
still get the work done so in early in
the spring if before all this grow up
and green up I'm not having a moment it
doesn't make sense for me to go out
there and spray PGR application
especially when we start thinking about
essentiality and what is essential
someone says what are you spraying in
here for that duck PGR application
probably better say for when you're
actually growing and okay I can't get
into motifs enough so just one more
question it's more to comment about
signage on the fields and talking about
liability so staying within county and
state guidelines and mandates have your
attorney review and approve take a
liability off your shoulders I mean this
is something you know we've never had to
think about liability of getting sick
from using an athletic field but able to
give Mike Greg you got a mic or
we can either see you so great to have
you here
this is exactly the kind of stuff we got
to make sure guys at least are able to
understand you take your mic off a mute
Greg if you got it I'll ask him for time
you if he wants to talk
do what you can if you're in a municipal
situation school district or something
like that by all means you need to check
internally about the regs that are going
to be required and what what Greg is
talking about here that's so valuable is
is is to post that stuff because if
you're going to minimal maintenance and
they're gonna use those fields you
telling them that you're going to
minimal maintenance you know somehow I'm
not a lawyer but somehow that seems to
me like something maybe you want to have
checked out by somebody and I think
Greg's a comment here about you know
getting it vetted by somebody who knows
things about liability is is the best
advice anybody can give you and we will
be adding that to our best management
practices for sports turf managers
especially because the reality is fellas
and gals and fellas and folks and guys
and all the different pronouns and that
I use these days you know people are
still gonna be out there using our
fields especially if they're home
they're doing things they don't normally
do which does two things they're not
familiar with the landscape sometimes
that they're walking through I worry
about this on golf courses in particular
then I used to be an out there and you
know stupid stupid stuff happens when
you're not used to doing things they go
on a field they date they step in a hole
they triple bugs and then you know even
in an age of pandemic I'm pretty sure
lawyers are working too so I would want
to be really careful about you know you
want people to use the fields gosh darn
it that's what they're there for
but mostly just to keep their distance
wander around get some fresh air and go
home
is essentially what everybody's been
telling us especially in New York thanks
very much Greg for those comments do you
have a mic you want to talk he might not
have a mic okay no problem all right
yeah so Carl any other questions how we
doing we're at a half an hour we did
yeah I think we got all the questions
okay yeah sorry dad maybe next time
yeah we'll bring you on next time better
join us in the future Greg a long time
nice to board member you know
professional sports turf manager not not
well enough recognized sometimes by
people across the state I'm sure in the
nicest circle certainly well recognizing
the sports turf circles just a
knowledgeable guy all around at
paletine down there in the Hudson Valley
so that's really good for everybody to
consider Carl we're at 10:30 what do you
want to do I think you know for this
week we'll wrap it up that's a good half
an hour segment got a couple questions
in there really talking about growth a
lot this weekend and really mowing is
what we deem essential in units it's
part of the Jeff's definition right that
it has to be mowed so thanks everybody
for coming this week
like I said we'll throw this up on
YouTube as a recording and then we'll be
back April 9th with our next discussion
that's Thursday against ticket 10:00
a.m. the session about sports turf
everybody all right thanks everybody
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu